hi Joe I read your question regarding
the developing countries and you make
the assumption basically that developing
countries seem not to be able to make it
on their own actually the first thing is
that I think that's the wrong assumption
if you look at the world today and if
you listen to most of the economic
information or news and the experts they
will tell you that actually now is the
time of the developing nations and it's
the it's the hour of the countries like
you know the China's and the Indians in
the Brazil's of the world and it's also
the chance for for this part of the
world for Mena for the delays that North
Africa I think it's important and in
your question you're also asking a
question about the Arab League and what
can the Arab League do to us and I think
as a young person and as somebody who's
looking forward to the future I think
stop looking for you know some kind of
authority to come and do something for
you or what the Arab League can do or
what governments can do I think what's
important is young people should really
take responsibility for the future and
take their own initiatives nothing
precludes you today from becoming an
entrepreneur yes it may be more
difficult for you to do it here than it
is maybe do it in the US or on some of
the more developed markets that have the
infrastructure for
or for young entrepreneurs but the key
point here is you know for you to have
your own dream and for you to actually
go after that dream and forget about you
know what somebody else can do for you
or whether there should be some
governmental policy and so on and so
forth there's enough flexibility in our
economies today for young people to go
out into the world and start doing
things so that would be my my my answer
to you take action yourself don't wait
for somebody else to do it for you and
developing nations are the future and
its people like you and your generation
that's going to make sure that the MENA
region actually becomes one of the
important global emerging market zones
that are going to spur growth